all hail northwest the reigning queen of
tick tock who just crushed an epic lip
sync of eminem's the real slim shady
with the help of her little sister
chicago west it's really lit and fun and
crazy yeah on sunday kim kardashian and
kanye west's eight-year-old and
three-year-old daughters proved the
apple doesn't fall far from the grammy
wedding tree when they put their spin on
the classic 2000 hit
i'm just extremely happy can you tell by
my face
no way you're kidding he didn't just say
what i think he did diddy and dr dre
said nothing idiots dr dre is dead he's
locked in my basement pretty impressive
right it's always so much fun
the sweet video also gives fans a close
look at the family's holiday decor
including huge trees lit up with lights
in the backyard
but this isn't the first time little shy
has made an appearance on her famous mom
and big sister's joint tick tock account
that's kim's youngest daughter back in
november riding on a golf cart with her
sister and her cousins khloe
kardashian's three-year-old daughter
true thompson and kourtney kardashian's
nine-year-old daughter penelope disick
i'm just like living life of course
penelope and her mom launched their own
joint tick tock back in october
[Music]
and the mother daughter duo shared their
own take on eminem's track last month
then on sunday p debuted a new do on the
social media platform it's really not
that bad it just needs a little
shaping
to the salon
[Music]
as for court she was feeling the holiday
spirit this year court just showed me
i'm really lazy
leading up to christmas kim pointed out
that the push founder's elf on a shelf
game was on a whole other level this is
what she showed me this year that i am
really
lazy and i need to get it together in
the final days
because i can't do this
court np also highlighted the impressive
display on their tick tock account
featuring a quick cameo from north
o
m
g
r else
are like
crazy
but back to little chicago i finally
have a really good idea for christmas
kim shared the family's holiday card
over the weekend they're all decked out
in what else kim's line skims though the
photo is missing a few famous family
members we do see the designer's kiddos
shy north and sons psalm and saint plus
her sister chloe and her daughter true
we also see their brother rob's daughter
dream and of course the family matriarch
kris jenner i'm obsessed with all of the
you know holidays and decorating
and twitter blew up with fans comparing
little shy to her supermodel aunt
kendall jenner with tweets like quote
chicago is coming for auntie kendall's
job and quote chicago is a natural watch
out kendall tbd if chicago will follow
in her famous aunt's catwalking
footsteps or if she'll take her dad's
musical lead
but either way kim told et back in 2017
that she just wants her kiddos to find
their own passions
i hope that they
just find their own motivation and no
matter what that is no matter what they
want to do in life i hope that they work
really hard and i think our kids will
see you know
kanye and i work really hard and i hope
that's motivating for them and just to
find their own path